cars burning guns firing people looting
images that have become all too familiar
in the united states as
of late anarchy in action on the streets
has got politicians pointing fingers at
each other
republicans are even staking their
re-election efforts on a
tough law and order stance saying that
democratic governors have let the
situation get out of hand
chaos results when failed officials
in cities like portland minneapolis
chicago and new york make the conscious
decision
not to support law enforcement the
violence and bloodshed we are seeing in
these and other cities
isn't happening by chance it's the
direct result
of refusing to allow law enforcement to
protect
our communities leftists try to turn
them into villains
they want to cancel them
but i'm here to tell you these heroes
can't be cancelled from seattle and
portland
to washington and new york democrat-run
cities across this country are being
overrun
by violent mobs those statements from
the south dakota governor did not make
it past
leftist media which called for a reality
check we will interject when we feel
like there's something that's important
and deliberate and very wrong
that should be corrected just so that we
feel responsible about our broadcast
other news outlets got much the same for
suggesting local authorities are
responsible for the violence
how shocked are we that 17-year-olds
with rifles decided they had to maintain
order
when no one else would this goes beyond
racism
tucker carlson is advocating and
defending murder
how shocked are we that tucker carlson
is praising murder as some kind of
vigilante hero
democrats are taking those blame claims
and throwing them
right back into the face of
conservatives saying that they're the
ones that fermented the hate to begin
with
the question for us wisconsin is when
are we going to make republicans do
their jobs
or do we continue to sit idly by and
watch this said burn to the
ground our nation is hurting
we need leadership that will heal our
wounds not continue to pour
salt on them peaceful protests against
police violence
should not be met with more violence and
yet
that's exactly what the president called
for after the death of george floyd
and here at home as george floyd
brianna taylor and a never-ending list
of
innocent people of color continue to be
murdered stating the simple fact that a
black life matters
is still met with derision from the
nation's highest
office as media and politicians blame
each other
some u.s citizens are taking up arms on
their own
in kenosha wisconsin a teenager said to
worship the police
went to a protest and opened fire on the
crowd
two people were killed the local police
then
chimed in on their own saying that the
victims were to blame
because they were on the streets in
violation of curfew laws
this is not a police action this is not
the action i believe of those who set
out to do protests it is involved it is
the persons who were involved
after the legal time involved in illegal
activity that brought violence to this
community
this teenager is not the only one
right-wing militia groups and black
self-defense organizations have
sprung up across the country while
politicians point the finger
the situation on the streets is only
getting worse
across the country people are bracing
for turbulent times ahead
i think there's a political game going
on this on this side
on both sides you've got the democratic
side trying to
to blame uh the president for stirring
racial uh
unrest and i don't necessarily agree
with that and you've got
um you've got the republican side saying
that
um especially they're pinpointing the
the finger at democratic leaders and
democratic cities and stuff
is that the leadership there is not
taking the appropriate action
there's no law and order and so there's
there needs to be a middle
someplace we do need law and order we
need to provide security and safety for
our families
security for our businesses especially
small businesses
i feel so bad for small businesses
they were so hit by the coronavirus and
those are the ones that are being
impacted a lot on this violence in the
city unfortunately it's a real situation
but
both parties are using it as a political
weapon
you